[MAN SPEAKS INDISTINCTLY]
- 20.
20.
[ENGINE REVVING]
- OOH.
- ARE YOU OKAY?
- WHOA, EVERYTHING WENT
BRIGHT AS [BLEEP].
- DUDE, DUDE.
- ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
- WHAT HAPPENED?
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
YOU OKAY?
- WHOA.
- IT'S ALL FUN AND GAMES
UNTIL SOMEONE GETS HURT.
AND THEN IT'S GOOD TELEVISION.
LEGALLY, I'M OBLIGATED TO SAY
DON'T TRY JUMPING
OVER A SLOW-MOVING CAR.
YOU GOT TO TRY IT WHEN
THE CAR'S GOING SUPER FAST.
THAT WAY, YOU DON'T HAVE TO STAY
IN THE AIR VERY LONG.
THAT HUMAN ROADKILL
GOES BY SHANE,
AND IT'S HARD
TO CLASSIFY WHAT HE DOES.
HE'S NOT
A PROFESSIONAL STUNTMAN.
HE'S NOT AN ATHLETE.
HE'S JUST YOUNG, DUMB,
AND FULL OF [BLEEP].
WHOSE [BLEEP]?
WELL, THAT'S SHANE'S BUSINESS,
ISN'T IT?
WOMEN DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHY GUYS DO STUPID THINGS
THAT INJURE THEMSELVES,
BUT IT'S NO DIFFERENT
THAN WHEN YOU GALS GET TOGETHER
TO HURT EACH OTHER'S FEELINGS.
DARES WORK BECAUSE
THE LONG-TERM EFFECTS
OF HEAD TRAUMA ARE MINOR
COMPARED TO THE PAIN
OF BEING CALLED A PUSSY.
I REFUSE ALL DARES
UNLESS IT'S MARC SUMMERS
DOUBLE DARING ME
TO DIG THROUGH A GIANT NOSE
FILLED FULL OF FAKE BOOGERS
TO FIND A LITTLE ORANGE FLAG.
AMATEUR STUNTS
ARE LIKE AMATEUR PORN,
EXCITING BECAUSE
NOBODY'S WEARING PROTECTION.
THAT'S WHY I FLEW SHANE
TO HOLLYWOOD,
WHERE BOYS WILL BE BOYS,
UNLESS THEY IDENTIFY OTHERWISE--
I DON'T JUDGE--
FOR THIS WEEK'S WEB REDEMPTION.
[THUDDING]
YOU EVER RUN OVER
A PARKED LIMOUSINE?
- NO.
- YEAH, THAT'S WHAT I THOUGHT.
I JUST DON'T GET THAT RUNNER'S
HIGH RUNNING OVER A COMPACT.
SHANE?
- YEAH.
- TELL ME ABOUT
THE AFTERLIFE.
- THE AFTERLIFE.
- DID YOU DIE?
- I'M NOT SURE.
- YOU DID--DEFINITELY SAID
EVERYTHING WENT BRIGHT.
- WHOA, EVERYTHING
WENT BRIGHT AS [BLEEP].
- DUDE, DUDE.
- ARE YOU ALL RIGHT?
- WHAT DO YOU THINK THAT WAS?
- I DON'T KNOW.
IT KIND OF FELT LIKE
A FLASH BANG GOING OFF.
IT WAS--IT WAS
PRETTY INTENSE.
- DID YOU GO
TO THE HOSPITAL?
- YES, RIGHT AFTERWARDS,
ACTUALLY.
- AND WHAT DID THEY
SAY WAS WRONG?
- NOTHING.
- NOT EVEN A CONCUSSION?
- NOPE, NONE OF THAT.
- THOSE AREN'T GOOD DOCTORS.
YOU SUCCESSFULLY
JUMPED OVER A--
BY THE WAY, WHY ARE YOU CALLING
IT JUMPING OVER A CAR?
YOU'RE RUNNING OVER A CAR.
- I'M NOT SURE.
- YOU GOT TO RENAME
YOUR STUNT.
- THAT'S SPLITTING HAIRS.
- WELL, I MEAN, YOU'RE
CLEARLY RUNNING OVER IT.
YOU SUCCESSFULLY RAN OVER IT
AT 10 MILES AN HOUR,
AND AT 20,
THINGS WENT WRONG.
DID YOU EVER CONSIDER
TRYING IT AT 15?
- NOPE, JUST FIGURED
WE'D DOUBLE IT.
- SO IF YOU WOULD HAVE
SUCCESSFULLY MADE 20,
YOU WOULD HAVE TRIED 40,
THEN 80, THEN 160,
AND THEN BROKEN THE RECORD
AT A WHOPPING--
WHAT'S 160 TIMES 2?
LET'S THINK ABOUT THAT.
SO YOU GOT 160 TIMES 2.
UH...
SO WHAT'S YOUR DEAL?
WHAT ARE--YOU GUYS
ARE A STUNT GROUP?
- MM-HMM, YEAH.
- HOW MANY MEMBERS?
- I DON'T KNOW; THERE'S BEEN
SOME THAT COME AND GO, BUT--
- YOU'VE LOST A FEW.
- YES.
- DO YOU PARTICIPATE
IN A LOT OF THEM OR NO?
- SOME OF 'EM, YEAH,
BUT I'M USUALLY THE ONE
HELPING AND FILMING.
- THAT'S THE SMARTER GIG.
- YEAH.
- WHAT'S THE WORST PAIN
YOU'VE EVER EXPERIENCED?
- I'M NOT SURE.
THAT IS A TOUGH QUESTION THERE.
- ALL RIGHT, YOU HAVEN'T
BEEN HURT TOO BAD.
- APPARENTLY NOT.
- NOT TOO BAD.
- I'VE NEVER BROKEN A BONE.
- KNOCK ON WOOD, THEN.
- YEAH, RIGHT?
- THAT'S NOT WOOD.
YOUR VIDEOS ARE CALLED:
BUT THEN YOU'RE
CALLED P.O.R.
WHICH IS IT?
- P.O.R.
BUT WE ARE THE WORLD'S
MOST DANGEROUS STUNT GROUP.
- AND P.O.R. STANDS FOR?
- PROPHETS OF REGRET.
- WHO CAME UP WITH THAT?
- I DO BELIEVE JJ.
- WHICH ONE'S HE?
- THE LEADER.
- OH!
- DAMN.
- DO YOU HAVE TO DO
WHAT HE SAYS?
- NO, NOT NECESSARILY.
- OKAY.
CAN PEOPLE BUY
THAT P.O.R. SHIRT?
- YEAH, ALL OVER THE WORLD.
- WHAT DO YOU MEAN, "BUY IT
ALL OVER THE WORLD"?
YOU MEAN GO ON YOUR
WEBSITE AND BUY IT?
- YEAH.
- HOW MUCH DOES IT COST?
- I'M NOT SURE.
- [LAUGHS]
- HOW'D YOU GET
INTO P.O.R.?
WERE YOU SEXED IN
OR STUNTED IN?
- [LAUGHS]
I WAS STUNTED IN.
- CAN ANYBODY
BECOME A MEMBER?
- DEPENDS ON WHAT
THEY'RE WILLING TO DO?
- SO YOU HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING TO PROVE.
- I DO BELIEVE.
- ANY WOMEN?
- NO.
- IS THERE A BAN ON WOMEN?
- NO, IT'S JUST,
I DON'T THINK ANY OF 'EM
REALLY WANT TO DO
THIS [BLEEP].
- SOME OF YOUR VIDEOS
HAVE BEEN ON OUR SHOW BEFORE,
HAVEN'T THEY?
THE ONE WITH THE--
A THE BOWLING BALL
DOWN THE SLIDE.
- YEP, THAT WAS
ONE OF 'EM, AND--
- WELL, I THINK I COULD
SUE YOU GUYS,
'CAUSE I TRIED
TO COPY THAT.
- YEAH?
- I DID IT OFF
A WATERPARK SLIDE.
AND IT BRUISED ME SO BAD
FOR, LIKE, A MONTH,
I REALLY COULDN'T USE.
IT WAS JUST HORRIBLE
TO THE TOUCH.
- WOW.
- I THOUGHT I HAD
CHEATED IT ENOUGH
BY USING A BALL
THAT BARELY WEIGHED,
LIKE, 5 POUNDS, BUT IT
STILL WAS WAY TOO MUCH.
- YEAH, IT GETS
THAT MOMENTUM.
- YEAH, THAT WASN'T
A GOOD IDEA.
THAT WAS THE DUMBEST THING
I'VE DONE ON THIS SHOW.
YOU HAVE ANY OTHER WEIRD,
DANGEROUS HOBBIES?
- I DON'T KNOW.
I MESS WITH ELECTRICITY.
THAT'S FUN.
- WHAT DO YOU DO
WITH ELECTRICITY?
- I'M AN ELECTRICIAN.
- OH.
[LAUGHS]
THAT'S--THAT'S GOOD, THEN.
- YEAH.
- YOU WANT TO BASE JUMP?
- THAT'D BE COOL.
- ALL THOSE PEOPLE
DIE EVENTUALLY.
- WINGSUITS.
- YOU WANT TO TRY A WINGSUIT?
- OH, YEAH, BUT YOU GOT
TO TRAIN FOR, LIKE, TWO YEARS
BEFORE YOU DO IT, THOUGH.
- WHO'S GOT THAT
KIND OF TIME?
JUMPING OVER CARS
IS PLAYED OUT.
EVEN KOBE BRYANT
IN HIS PRIME
COULDN'T JUMP OVER A CAR
WITHOUT FAKING IT,
AND HE'S BEEN
ACCUSED OF RAPE.
- ALL RIGHT, WHAT
DO YOU GOT IN MIND?
- SHANE, NOW YOU LOOK LIKE
A PROFESSIONAL STUNTMAN.
SORRY WE WOULD ONLY
AFFORD ONE HELMET.
OKAY, HERE'S THE PLAN.
WE'RE GONNA LOCK
YOU UP TIGHT.
I'M GONNA GUN IT,
HOPEFULLY GET THIS P.O.S.
UP TO 20 TO 100 MILES PER HOUR.
THEN I'M GONNA SLAM
ON THE BRAKES.
IF MY CALCULATIONS
ARE CORRECT,
PHYSICS AND YOUR NATURAL
INSTINCT TO SURVIVE
WILL SKIP YOU ACROSS THE POND
SAFELY TO THE OTHER SIDE,
WHERE I HAVE A CHILLED BOTTLE
OF MARTINELLI'S SPARKLING CIDER
WAITING FOR YOU.
OKAY, NOW, I DIDN'T KNOW
HOW OLD YOU WERE
OR IF YOU HAD A PROBLEM,
SO I PLAYED IT SAFE
WITH THE CIDER.
IT'S THE WORLD'S
MOST DANGEROUS STUNT.
I CALL IT THE BRAKE N' LAKE.
- [EXHALES SHARPLY]
[FUNKY MUSIC]
♪ ♪
- YOU READY, SHANE?
- I'M GOOD.
♪ ♪
- AMERICA!
[ENGINE TURNS OVER]
[ENGINE REVVING]
[SUSPENSEFUL MUSIC]
♪ ♪
[TIRES SCREECH]
[DRAMATIC MUSIC]
♪ ♪
SHANE! SHANE!
[FLARE POPS AND WHOOSHES]
[FLARE BANGS]
HELP IS ON THE WAY,
BUDDY.
- WHOO!
DID I MAKE IT?
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
- IF HE HADN'T LIED
ABOUT HIS WEIGHT,
HE WOULD HAVE MADE IT
ALL THE WAY ACROSS THE LAKE.
OH, WELL.
MORE MARTINELLI'S FOR ME.